I have the inordinate benefit of having
gone completely broke and once you've
gone completely broke you really don't
care what other people think
because you figure out most of them
aren't going to be around anyway it's
like watching a fighter that's been
knocked out they're a little Wilder the
next time because they oh that's what
happens oh that's how it works I didn't
die from it now I'm gonna I'm gonna lean
in here and you know I love folk and I I
want you to win and I want to help you
but
um I'm not really taking a poll
you know before I make a decision on
stuff I'm not I'm just I lost what the
Bible calls fear of man I just don't
I don't need affirmation to make good
quality value-based decisions I make
those decisions regardless and if I get
some affirmation that's wonderful I'm
like anybody else I like it but I don't
have to have that to do anything and
honestly when some of you get pissed off
it kind of inspires me